foreign
I have this issue where I have cut out
my dad for being very toxic it's been
over a year I find myself looking at the
settings on my phone and I'll look be
like has he contacted me you are not
alone sister Jackie
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John Maloney show
greatest mental health podcasts ever
says nobody so glad that you're with us
if you want to be on this show we talk
about marriage talk about relationships
we talk about trauma we talk about
whatever's going on in your life right
um if you want to be on the show give me
a call at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and we'll
hollaback girl at you even if you ain't
no hollaback girl and we'll give you a
call and see if we can get you on the
show or you can go to John deloney.com
ask a s k
um
we are heading I guess this will be out
as we're into the fall
um this episode's so start thinking
about Thanksgiving now start thinking
about Christmas now and your travel
plans if you're not going to travel
should let people know just say hey this
isn't going to be the year we're going
to do that don't forget to go pick up
some questions for humans cards for
those who are going to be traveling I've
actually started using the cards that my
own cards
um with my Tuesday morning breakfast
with my son and it's been incredible
it's so good and we'll use them when
we're traveling around on our hunting
Adventures this fall so don't forget to
pick those up at johnolony.com all right
let's go to Gainesville Florida and talk
to
Jackie what's up Jackie
hi John how are you good what are you
doing
not much just sitting on my lunch break
your lunch for I guess where I got some
hours differences
very cool all right so what's up
so my questions
do you move on from toxic family members
that you've cut out of your life
um I have this issue where I have cut
out my dad for being very toxic and
um it's been over a year
but I still find myself going on
Facebook and looking through like my
grandma's profile his mom
to see what he's up to I find myself
looking at the settings on my phone
because you can see your blocked
messages and I'll look to be like has he
contacted me and so I've done some
self-reflection about it and I think
I've gotten to the point where I feel
like I need to be validated in my
decision to do that
um
but
I don't think that's the right way to
find that validation and I don't know if
you would be able to help me out with
that yeah I think I can
um and thank you for sharing that that's
You Are Not Alone sister Jackie there
you that's such a common response to the
hard Brave thing he did which is to set
down boundaries what happened like there
was some moment when you said enough is
enough you've been dealing with this
your whole life
and it escalated what happened why'd you
finally say no more
pregnant with my first okay and
and different states and most of our
Communications through text
um when I was growing up I watched him
be
um sort of abusive towards my ex-stepmom
and
he was emotionally abusive manipulative
and
um
so I went through all that and I see him
he's kind of like my bear like he I'm
uncomfortable around him talking to him
and stuff okay and as I got older and
started a family of my own
um
I realized like the negativity that he
brings into my life
was just too much and when I was
pregnant I realized it kind of escalated
and then I got pregnant with my second
and
I just realize he's not the type of
person I wanted around my kids if I'm so
uncomfortable around him absolutely
and so oh sorry so did a thing finally
happen
did he say the wrong thing did he swear
at you fine or did he make a comment
about your husband like what happened
all the time
um well not all the time it'd be like
months in between but every time we
would text he eventually would get to
the point like I wish we were better I
wish you would get over what happened in
the past and I would tell him
um I'm sorry that's something that I'm
working on I'm in therapy and
um he would blame me for not contacting
him more and he would even blame my mom
which he divorced 20 years ago that she
like
um
put me against him and everything he's
the one that would badmouth my mom while
I was growing up so let me tell you this
your your dad is a child
and your dad's a coward
and he cares more about his
him propping up his own ego to himself
than he does about his relationship with
his daughter and his new grandkids
and those are things you have felt for a
long long time probably no one's ever
said him like that
and I know it's hard to hear but it's
the truth and if you don't hear that
you're going to continue to think you're
crazy for protecting yourself and your
little kids and you're not
because that man's going to use you and
now he's going to use your grandkids
to prop up his own ego like he's tried
to do for so long you know what what
matters 20 years ago not a lot
I'm way more concerned that he hasn't
gotten his car and driven to your house
and knocked on your door
with tears in his eyes
and said I'm so sorry I'm your dad
and more so than any of my stupid
arguments or blaming you I should have
shown up and been your dad and I wasn't
I'm sorry
he doesn't do that
he launches Text Grenades at you every
once in a while and they burrow into
your heart and then you feel crazy
right
so what you did was the right thing and
I want to just for all the people
listening
you did something
um that was so wise
um and I want to just call it out
you don't like who you become when
you're around him
and often that impacts our children more
so than any dumb comment or anything
like that
they know that walking into this house
mom begins to feel like X or act like X
or she becomes why and then these kids
get unmoored by that and so you saying I
don't like who I become around you
I'm stepping out of this thing
good for you I'm proud of you Jackie
it's hard what you did and I'm proud of
you
now here's the next part
I can I can ask you this question but
we'll just cut to the chase
you spent a lifetime being told that
what you believe is not trustworthy what
you feel is not trustworthy
oh isn't that the truth okay especially
by him there you go so it makes a
hundred percent sense that you finally
acted and you don't trust yourself
so you did the right thing
Okay so
recognizing that is part one
part two is acting differently now okay
so I don't want to overthink this
get off social media
or block your grandmother too
and start having human to human
conversations make it to where you there
was a season I was out of control with
my spinning I was just a maniac man we
finally make I was finally getting a
real paycheck for the first time in my
life and I was just Bonkers and at some
point I took my debit card out of my
wallet and gave it to my wife
I I had that little self-control
and I had to show up to a few places
where I'd already eaten and I realized
afterwards I didn't have my you know I
mean because it was just a I learned the
hard way but that's what that was how
drastic I got I think that's where you
are because here's what you have to do
you have to practice trusting yourself
and you've never done that before
and your kids need you to do that your
husband needs to do that you need to do
that
but if you've got that prop that crutch
to fall back on to see is he screwing
something up is he being a knucklehead
is he still with that woman whatever the
thing is that you keep going back
um you're gonna keep doing it
you got to practice
is that fair
yeah let me ask you this
um well I'll just say it this way brene
Brown calls it rehearsing tragedy
do you sit
um and I love that it's just a dress
rehearsal for for a tragedy
how often do you sit and just have
imaginary conversations with this guy
all the time
how often do you have imaginary
conversations with your mom like she's
finally gonna just ask you that one
right question and you're gonna unload
or your girlfriend never she's like my
best friend she already knows everything
okay so
rumination just spinning out thinking
about it thinking about it thinking
about it that feels like good helpful
thinking
it feels like there's a Potential Threat
down the road and we're going to think
through how we're going to respond ahead
of time
the idea of it sounds good
hear me say this is as boldly as I can
rumination and worry is a complete and
utter waste of your time
in fact it steals from your children it
steals from your partner it steals from
you
because it takes you from the present
and it spins your body up your body
actually goes to war for you
it actually it's it's like oh there's
not even a bear here
um but we can conjure one up in our
brains and then we can respond to it
and you see what I'm saying and you get
out of the shower and you've been
sitting there having these imaginary
conversations in the shower for some
reason I hear all over the country
people have these in the shower I think
usually that's finally when people get
still enough in a day where they can
just that water's relaxing a little bit
and then they can the machine just kicks
up right me too
so listen Jackie I wish it was more
complicated than this quit
quit
stop having an imaginary conversations
with your dad that you are never gonna
have in real life
as my friend Todd says he doesn't have a
meteorite plan
so if a meteorite comes we will he will
deal with the economic Fallout of that
when it happens
and I'll tell you your dad's probably
not going to knock on your door and say
I'm so sorry
do you forgive me he's probably not
and so feel free to deal with that if it
ever happens it probably won't
and stop giving him rent-free space in
the middle of your chest
stop giving him rent-free space in the
middle of your marriage in the middle of
your parent of your kids in the middle
of your of your heart and head is that
fair
yeah it is
you're entering into the holiday season
right we're going to get into October
November December
this is going to be extra hard is it
yeah especially if I'm thinking about
visiting the family in that state don't
why would you do that
because I love everybody else
do you get anxious when you're around
them
mainly him okay if he's there don't go
okay
because then you're just you know I mean
you're trying to have your cake needed
too you drew a boundary maybe at some
point you let them know I've chosen to
not be around him because these
gaslighting and manipulative and abusive
and he still won't take any ownership of
the way he treated me and my family
um and if you all choose to invite him
then then y'all are choosing for us to
not come and that's totally cool you can
do that you can put the ball in their
Court
but I don't see anything wrong with you
taking a year off
and just deciding opting for solving for
peace this holiday season
and that means you're gonna have to
grieve it you're gonna be sad you're
going to miss out on to this and that's
and you can't just do nothing you got to
backfill it with then we're going to go
here we're going to go do this thing or
we're gonna go try this thing but do
something else
give your heart and mind and soul and
home arrest
is that possible
does that sound like ah or like what are
you feeling when I'm saying this
it does sound like ax
um it sounds like ah like scared or ah
like peaceful
um specific but uh it's peaceful
definitely peaceful
oh dude solve for solve for freedom
foreign
which you probably don't have enough of
with two little ones right
oh absolutely not
what about just having a peaceful
holiday season
and all you have to do is just send an
email to your family says hey we're not
traveling this this year
I have a very different situation with
my family like I love my family like
hanging out with them
um and I sent the email yesterday
to all of them that said I let myself
get out of control last fall with all my
travel and I had a book deadline dude it
just got chaotic and then hosting the
holidays I became someone I don't like I
didn't like
I wasn't the dad I wanted to be the
family member of the friend the husband
I wasn't I wasn't the guy one to be so
this year we're not hosting
and so I'm letting y'all know way up way
in advance three or four months y'all
need to buy plane tickets and come out
here we're not going to do a big old
thing
um we're gonna come to your house on
this day if y'all can make it great if
you don't if it's not a good time for
y'all we won't come
but we just decided all right I decided
man I need I need to recalibrate I need
peace
and then I'm going to figure out how I
can best honor my family on the back end
of that see what I'm saying so maybe
this year you write your family letters
tell me love them and you miss them and
wish them well and send them a note says
we're not going to travel this year and
then just
whoo relax right
right
that sound good
it does it's I guess um it can be a
little heartbreaking not being able to
see everybody else and do you get that a
heartbreak is okay
fun it's not pleasant but it's right
like it makes sense that you're
heartbroken
most the time when somebody puts up we
put up a boundary with somebody who's um
blown up our lives
we don't recognize the impact of that
boundary and still until people start
banging their head up against it and
what I mean by that is we like we think
that we can put up a boundary around one
person one friend one Community member
one husband or ex-wife or one you know
somebody struggling with addiction
whatever that is
um
but we don't realize that you can't very
rarely can you put up a boundary around
somebody in isolation it usually impacts
an entire system and your body's gonna
have to get used to the fact that you're
dead blew up everything
right
right and blaming him and sitting there
wallowing in that and getting mad at it
that doesn't solve any of your issues
what solves your issues is saying cool
I'm not going to be around that I'm not
gonna have my kids around that I'm gonna
create something new and that's annoying
and hard and I don't want to but that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do something new
and I'm gonna solve for Freedom not like
Freedom not like political not I'm gonna
solve for peace I'm gonna solve for
sleep I'm gonna solve for
rest I'm gonna solve for laughter and
it's all for kindness and patience I'm
gonna solve for whoo
that we can all use a little bit more of
that
thanks for the call Jackie we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right cool let's go to uh Dustin in
Sanford Florida what's up Dustin
hey what's up brother just hanging out
how are you doing today dude I'm doing
the exact same thing I'm running this
this scam over here called a uh YouTube
show it's awesome
[Laughter]
thank you man so what's up brother how
can I help
so I've got like 50 million different
changes going on in life right now
um and I'm just trying to I guess that's
just the season um that I'm in but the
big question
um I guess I really have with everything
um is
um with the current transition uh
transitioning out of the military
um into civilian life and how long you
been in uh I did uh eight and a half
years
uh what was your role
um for those years
um I was uh Infantry
um and then the last half of that was uh
Aviation uh worked on uh helicopters oh
so you've seen it huh yeah man yeah
all the nitty-gritty stuff oh yeah yeah
and it's like
I'm at this um turning point in my life
where
for the first time I'm really getting to
make my own decisions and
I guess my the question
um is do I
wear that
um my service time as a badge of Pride
and honor whatever
or do I just
put it all behind me and just completely
honestly isolate but leave that military
Community behind what's that what's the
impetus
what's that why you've boxed yourself
into an either or
why do you feel the need to make that
call
I think a lot of it for me is
like we've just moved it you know we
just moved into a new house and you know
for the first time like I don't have to
put on the uniform every day
um and so like I've got a tough box in
the middle of my living room right now
um like filling up with
you know uniforms and stuff and I look
at that and
um
like every time I open it like my heart
starts racing yeah
why does it start racing
is
just
a lot of like the mental
um things I guess I just haven't like
processed
um
can I tell you what I think it is yeah
you've seen a lot of stuff right you've
seen a lot of the worst of the worst
and you've seen the word good wrapped up
in some pretty messy evil and you've
seen the word evil wrapped up in like
that's not so bad right you've seen it
all
um
and when we say see it all people most
people have watched the movies and
you've seen it and experienced it and
felt it
I don't necessarily
think that's what it is
for the last eight years so let's just
say decade
you've had a purpose and a mission and a
role
and you've had people who
manicured every moment of your day
and more importantly
you fixed a helicopter
surrounded by sand and smoke and other
people had guns and they were laying
their life on the line so you could do
your job
you have an insight into what tribe and
community and friendship and loyalty
looks like that most people will never
understand
and I think this is completely me okay I
think a big part of the PTSD crisis that
we have from people returning
is we drop them off and say go make good
choices and here's some pamphlets go get
them
and it's unmooring yes they've seen hard
things but if you look at the trauma
literature people who experience hard
things in the context of loving adult
relationships do okay over time
and I think your body knows more than I
will ever know
we're about to be real real lonely we're
about to find ourselves out in the
middle of a battlefield and our team
left us and we know what that means
right
that's my guess is that you were you're
losing or you are opting out of
everything and that doesn't mean it's
the wrong thing it's actually the right
thing for you man you've put in you put
in your decade it's time it's cool
I think your body knows that is that
fair man I'm I'm I haven't come home
from combat veteran world so you could
tell me I'm off
it is like
you know we've
well actually we just we just uh I got
out
um well living in Hawaii and so we're
transitioning from Hawaii and now we're
living all the way completely on the
other let's move to the other side of
the the country we're down in Florida
now and so it's like adjusting to that
it's you know adjusting to
a new work environment a new work
community and
like
um you know trying to
make all these new adjustments into
things and trying to
can I can I like your language is that
of a car mechanic
I need to make it or or a helicopter
mechanic right I've got to make an
adjustment here I gotta tighten this
rolling girder spring thing over here
and the right
let me
challenge you
to not look at what's before you as a
series of knobs to turn and wrenches to
crank
for the first time in a long time you
are gonna have to feel stuff
and feeling stuff in many ways would
have got you killed the last decade and
now it's the thing that's going to keep
you alive
and it's a set of skills that you don't
have and so you're gonna have to
practice it
is that fair definitely and I mean I'm
sure I'm trying like of course you are
of course dude you're awesome of course
you are man like don't have me clowning
on you I just want to give you a
different like you're gonna you're
naturally gonna try to solve problems
with the way that you've solved problems
before and you have had the opportunity
to solve problems with bullets flying at
you and with other people with people's
like dying or dead next to you like
you've had to solve problems and so it's
natural that man all this change all
this chaos all this ah I'm going to go
back to what I know what I've been
trained to do which is to break this
thing down and to adjust
right
right and like you know I'm
do we just like last night
um had our first night of like small
groups and like trying to get plugged in
with that and and hey that's the worst
man right it's like is the worst because
the last time they sent you to basic
and y'all did push-ups and PT you know
did all this crap together and you
looked up six months later and you were
a you you were one
and now you're sitting around with a
bunch of like Suburban dads like hey man
you know what's really tough the air
conditioning and you're like nope not
tough not tough
um and uh my lawnmower wouldn't start
that's it's Obama's fault and you're
like no no not a thing it's right so
you've got this ringside seat and the
challenge for you
is to choose it's gonna be hard
is to choose to find community in new
places
and dude it's so you're how old are you
30 31 30 yeah okay it's the worst it's
it's the worst
making friends as a 30 and four-year-old
it's the worst but you have to have
people in your tribe and your gang and
you are gonna have to all veterans are
have to understand that it won't be like
it was and dude
you and I both know veterans who are 55
and whenever they get together they go
back and tell stories back when they
were 19. the same as you and I both have
like yeah Bros who are high school
football heroes and they get together
and they tell the same football stories
and here's why because that's the last
time they were part of something bigger
than themselves
and the military gives you that in an
extraordinary way
and the mission before you now is I you
are going to have to opt into that it's
not going to be presented for you
and that's just a set of skills man
is that fair
yeah definitely definitely
um what you do what's your new what's
your new mission
or well played no what's your new
Mission your job will feed your mission
what is your what's your objective
um
I don't know right now I'm just trying
to uh that's it I don't even know what
your answer is you you're gonna be feel
aimless and purposeless
and when your body's untethered
then your body will ring the anxiety
alarms
and when you don't have people in your
life you don't have a gang in your
corner
um your body will ring the anxiety
alarms
and it's gonna be hard to get out of bed
you're gonna snap at your wife you're
going to just roll your eyes to some
dude is wearing loafers and no socks and
he's like let me tell you what's going
on in the world and you'll be like dude
just shut up you don't know
and all of that is going to feel like
the problem that that
box full of your gear in the middle of
your living room is going to feel like
the problem and it's not
what's your mission
I think it's just um
just trying to get like reconnected like
my wife kids
um like Community around me and
everything it's just what's your mission
because I mean because I think it's a
lot of it's just been like being yeah
just being lonely right now like
foreign
yeah yeah because it's just like
I feel like at times like
you know
that
person in a room and I'm like hey like
let's you know talk about whatever I
never really you know I work with a
bunch of
um veteran guys and it's like they just
it's like constantly like oh yeah back
when I was in the Army too I'm like dude
I don't want to talk about that like
it's it's exhausting it's like
I just want like
and that's like where it where it all
boils down to it's like
I feel like in One Direction like I want
to put it all like the military and
everything like behind me and and move
on
but I'm constantly surrounded by
other people that have been in that
community
and it's like I don't necessarily know
if I
want to be there you know yeah totally
and you find yourself in in the odd man
out right you're a no man's land
right which is a really lonely unmooring
place to be
so I
I did uh Jenna and Kelly let me know
this call was coming so I reached out to
two different people
one is a friend of mine and she's
actually on deployment right now
um she's wrapping up like in two months
and then another one is a close buddy of
mine who's a seal who's just rolling off
okay
and the roll-off process for them for
for him has been a quite a season and I
just asked them
that question
because I get the that question you're
asking makes sense
is this just a chapter of my life and
now I move on and I gotta start wearing
really short khaki shorts like is this
is this what's next
um or do I have to just keep like
talking about military stuff for the
rest of my life is that forever right
and do I cut this group out do I cut out
and so I'm gonna read you directly what
they wrote me is that cool yeah man they
have a better they get to I've sat with
a bajillion vets they're living it and I
have it and I want to honor their voice
okay
here's what one of them wrote
I think happiness in life is achieved
through balance so going all in or
cutting it all off probably isn't the
answer
I recommend keeping in touch with
veterans and being part of a community
but don't allow it to be your identity
you're a Time the military is part of
your story but it's not your complete
identity As you move into the next
chapter offer yourself a Grace if you
find yourself struggling in certain
aspects wherever you'll go you'll always
be so take the most loving version of
yourself live a life of balance
compassion and love
and he writes everything on the planet
is meant to serve something other than
itself and humans aren't the exception
focus on loving and serving others over
being self-centered and things will work
out
when I ask you what your mission is
getting connected to your wife getting
connected to your kids getting connected
making new friends all of those things
are actions in service of a bigger
picture you do those things because
they're right and they're holy and
they're good but those are the only way
you can be a light in your community you
can do good work you can pave new
sidewalks for my kids that are coming up
behind yours right whatever the bigger
mission is and what you've got in your
head is a whole bunch of tasks
and we've got to come up with a bit with
a mission right where are we going to
serve what's that going to look like
we're all in service to something
what are we going to serve and then how
are we going to get to that service
um the other buddy she says
if you stay connected
you'll have so many resources available
to you that you can explore
she mentioned Military One Source set
her up with a great civilian counselor
start unpacking stuff and repack all
that in a way that's healing to you
I would take advantage of the resources
I would also
tell those guys hey we're all I'm we're
going out I'm buying the first round no
military talk
call it out
and two or three of them are gonna go oh
thank God
foreign
that's not gonna be one of my guys
that's fine
it's fine
how does that sound
it sounds good I mean it
it's
bro
yeah it no it's just uh
I don't know I guess I gotta get to that
part of going out with the guys type
thing man I'm just uh let's Dustin
Dustin you don't got to do anything
right now
foreign
you've been going for a decade
you've had your minute by minute planned
out for 10 years
people have shot at you
and now you're just going to work
give yourself a minute
uh my buddy Ian simkin says if if
busyness
is a drug
rest will feel like torture
does it ever
right and you've been busy
to keep you alive you've been busy doing
what other people told you to do for 10
years you just got to learn a new thing
man that's it
you've been a running back forever and
they just stuck you out wide receiver
you got to give yourself some Grace you
don't run past routes before just new
you're not broken or damaged or ruined
or an idiot or none of those things bad
guy gotta learn new stuff it's cool man
you're gonna trip and fall hit in the
head with a ball you're gonna drop a few
passes it's fine
has there ever been one thing that
you've had laid in front of you that you
just said I walked away from and said I
can't do this
never really been an option there you go
this one's not either
so all of this starts with with
um one big scary proposition
sit down your wife
and letting her know hey honey for the
first time in my life I'm scared like in
a real way
not scared someone's gonna shoot me I'm
scared that I don't know what comes next
and then I don't have the skills to move
forward
can we do this thing together because
we're going to build something totally
new
and I'm almost guaranteed she'll
probably weep with you and say I'm all
in is that you think so
okay
take a big deep breath as deep as you
can those big dust and lungs
and hold it
five four
three
exhale and drop your shoulders all the
way down
you deserve sleep
ramp bunch of sex with your wife
laughter with your kids paycheck a safe
home
and you're just going to learn new
skills are you in
definitely 100 yeah
my kids have their life because the guys
like you
so from guy to guy thank you
appreciate that
and that's not a platitude and that's
just that's not some little thing I'm
gonna put on a sign and post it on
Instagram that's me telling my brother
Dustin thank you
and I'll walk with you as much like can
you call me every show if you want we'll
just have Dustin section every show as
you figure this thing out because listen
you're you're you're one of the Brave
few because there's Millions walking
through this just like you and they
think they're crazy they think it's
their wife's gone mad they think that
their husband's an idiot they think that
their kids are
and their bodies are screaming at them
hey we're alone we're not we're not safe
their bodies are screaming at them
saying we've got no mission
where are we going to serve next
and then we're gonna backfill that cool
definitely I love you man and I'm
grateful for you
foreign
thank you thank you thank you homework
assignment number one ask those
knuckleheads that you work with we're
going out we're all going out in not one
military conversation in fact I'm gonna
make it so weird for you
oh okay this is I can't even think of
this I'm gonna make it super weird I'm
gonna send you a few questions for
humans packs and I know I know when you
pull them out those guys are going to
look at you as though you've just gotten
a fourth head
as though you were like hey you mind if
I like kiss all y'all's wives That's
Another gonna look at you and you're
gonna say nope we're doing this and it's
going to give you some Avenue however
much grief you're gonna take for this
Avenue
then they come up with a pack for
veterans man just to give them something
to talk about other than hey remember
the time
practice new skills how to have
conversations how to look into the
future instead of living that past
um stay on the line here Jenna's gonna
hook you up we'll give you I'll give you
a bunch of them
um and give you all something to talk
about
[Music]
proud of you and I'm grateful for you my
brother we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right let's go north of the border
to Ontario and talk to Cindy what's up
Cindy
hey Cindy
you're Sydney
sorry I'm a little nervous hi doctor
I'll go by Cindy I'll go by sending this
call you goodbye John I'll go by Cindy
let's do this this will be hyper
confusing all right so what's up
um well thank you for taking my call I'm
a huge fan of yours and I listen to your
show every day
um I'm a little bit obsessed hey um hey
there's only there's about 22 of us now
so thank you for being one of the few
it's awesome
so you're welcome
um the reason for my call today is about
my husband's alcohol addiction
um I have two questions one my family
and I want to know how to deal with my
husband's drinking at family functions
and parties
and two is limiting his access to funds
considered Financial abuse if I'm
protecting our finances from his
addiction
so let me unpack that a bit so that you
can get some background on what's
Happening
um I'm a bit nervous and I I don't want
to forget anything so I hope you don't
mind me reading from my notes that's
great
um okay great
um I feel like my my children and I are
being gaslighted by my husband about his
addiction
um we ask him ahead of family functions
or parties
to either not drink or to limit his
drinking and he'll promise but he rarely
keeps it and especially if he has access
to unlimited uh beer like a wedding or
special occasion
so at parties he'll help himself to
other people's beer after he's finished
his own which angers me so much because
it's not they're not his to take
um
is timetable basically revolves around
work and drinking after work he works in
the evenings most night so on those
night tea drinks
um his five tall cans and goes to bed if
he's off work for the day he usually
starts drinking by three in the
afternoon
how old are your kids
um they're adults they're both close to
30. how long have you been living with
us
um probably about that long
are you done
no I'm not I'm not done why why why
you lived with this for so long
why
he's such a good person and
I don't want to split up the family I we
both came from broken homes and I don't
want to ever I just don't want it to
family Cindy you are living in a fantasy
you didn't break this family up
your husband chose to not heal from his
addiction not get the help he needed
and for 30 years he's told you that
you have to do this and you're the
reason for this and
you've had to manage that and you had
two kids grow up in this mess with an
alcoholic father
yeah and you've got guilt over that
and you've got guilt over all of it
enough
you're not breaking this family up Cindy
you're staying safe and I think he can
be a
um
I don't want to attach a morality to it
but the good men in my life do hard
things on behalf of their wives and kids
the men in my life the good men in my
life the people I would say that's a
good man
looks in a mirror and says I've got to
be different starting now I've screwed
up and I have to make major changes
I know good good men who've cheated on
their spouses and they've taken a knee
and said I screwed this thing up I know
good men who've stolen and who've lied
and said here's I'm going to be on the
back end of that car wreck
and your husband is chosen
not to remain an addict but he has
chosen to not get help
he um one time said that he was going to
go into rehab and I was crying tears of
happiness and
it then um coveted hit and he ended up
talking to an addiction counselor over
the phone and then it just stopped and
he went back to his drinking and you
went back to your fantasy
yeah I guess so
I'm not in the business of telling
people to get divorced that's not what I
do
I am in the business of telling people
that they deserve to be loved and they
deserve to be well and you deserve to
have a night of sleep and you deserve to
go to a party and laugh and have joy and
not worry that the person you brought is
going to make a drunken fool of
themselves and hurt people
yeah
you deserve to tell your kids I'm so
sorry
that I didn't stand up for y'all earlier
in this mess
and from this point forward we're going
to do different things you can do that
or you can make peace with the fact that
I'm choosing to stay with an alcoholic
and this is what that comes with
that's the choice you can make too but
what you're doing is you're trying to
have one thing while doing the other
thing and you're making yourself crazy
yeah right
yes gotta own the reality
nothing you've tried in 30 years would
give you any data any sort of indication
that he's going to quit drinking is that
fair
yes that's true okay so let's let's just
take that as a given he has chosen
alcohol as his way of coping with the
hard stuff in his past and in his
present and potentially in his future
so the only thing you can control is
your thoughts and your actions
[Music]
you came up with an agreement a few
years ago
because I told him I'm sick of his
drinking and
I told him that what is this what does
his drinking do to you does he does he
hit you
no oh God no he's he's wonderful in
every other way
he is a happy drunk he doesn't get
abusive in any way at all why do you
want to quit drinking
it's the drunkenness it's the behavior
he said you said he's wonderful
conversation she said he's lovely
wonderful he's a happy guy
he
inside of his drinking
okay
yeah when he's under the influence he
basically just sits easily with his head
down and just kind of you can't really
have a normal conversation with him he
just he gets this look in his face that
just
it's just not
um how many days a week how many days a
week does he drink
seven
so when is he this happy-go-lucky guy he
drinks every day
if in the evening during the day he
doesn't he doesn't drink at work he
doesn't drink at home when
when
we're off it's it usually if he's off
during the day he'll start around three
o'clock in the afternoon
and
he'll usually be in bed by eight or nine
and during the week when he comes home
from work because he works weeknights a
lot Cindy Cindy you're not being honest
with yourself
you're not being honest with yourself
you're telling yourself things that are
simply not true
foreign
this has to be incredibly expensive
it is
he was spending
before about five or six hundred a month
and
we got it down to 300 now
but he will
what I've actually done is I opened up a
bank account in my own name and I put
all the bills
through that account and he agreed to
this I transfer over ten dollars a day
which will get him five tall cams
and
and then he'll call me and say can you
top it up I need a bit of gas or I need
lunch money and then he'll spend some of
that on more beer and if I say that to
him he'll say it's my money I worked for
it it's my money just transfer it over
and then he's going out driving around
on recycling days looking for empty beer
cans or liquor bottles so he can take
them back for the deposit and he'll use
that to top up his drinking it's just
ridiculous but you contribute you
participate
[Applause]
you're giving him an alcohol allowance
Cindy
and he's right you
I know I know
I know
if I give him free reign he'll go back
to spending between 16 and 24 a day you
cannot control what another adult
chooses to do you can only control you
this is our finances I know you aren't
safe Cindy
do you work
yes I do
are you would you be able to support
yourself
um
probably yeah
if you reached out to your two 30 year
old kids and said it's time would they
weep tears of joy and come help you
they would
yeah
they have a lot of issues with him and
yeah I imagine so why do you think so
little of yourself
um and that's a mean unfair question I
know but why because the person I'm
hearing on the phone is a person who's
in the had enough
and you're not dumb you're real smart
[Music]
I don't know I just I I just don't
I guess because my we both came for
broken families I don't I don't want to
be that person I want to make things
work I keep trying to no I know I know
your heart's so good you're fit it's
already broken
what you have is a home on the inside of
it that's completely burned out and you
keep repainting the exterior
and you're that and you can stand out in
the front yard and be like look at this
home look how nice it is
yeah it's not and you know that
in the ultimate I know you are I can
hear it on you
in the ultimate form of
I guess you can call it gaslighting
you've now become
your marriage has been weaponized now
now it's your fault if he does or
doesn't drink now you're stealing his
money you see how you've become the
villain in this by trying to keep him
alive
yeah you're not the bad guy you are
participating make no mistake
and I know you feel stuck I get that
but at the end of the day he's a
grown-up and he's an alcoholic and he's
choosing to drink his uh to hide
foreign
what should I do in terms of finances
I think you need to sit down with one of
your older kids
and be very very clear on a spreadsheet
or a yellow pad for crying out loud
possibly get with a financial planner
and get a very clear reality of where
you live
how much debt do you owe what is rent in
the area cost all those hard questions
but at some point you walk in and you
say I'm not going to be your mom anymore
try to keep you alive for 30 years and
in the process of about darn near killed
myself
oh you don't love me anymore you're not
gonna no
I love you so much that I'm not going to
carry this anymore
yeah right I'm not your social worker
I'm not your mom I'm your wife
yeah
and I'm not going to go down on the ship
with you
and these are so these are I can think
of very few boundaries that are harder
when somebody that you love is actively
struggling with addiction actively
hurting themselves and at some point you
say
I love you but you can't do that here
and if you do that here you are by your
actions because behavior is a language
you are asking me to leave
because I'm worth more than this and you
know if I leave he's going to drink
himself sideways
yeah he is
and that is a choice a grown-up is going
to make
you can call the police and have them do
a welfare check you can call social
services and see if they'll reach out
and you can walk with him hold his hand
into rehab or into a counseling you can
go
but you can't make him stop drinking
no
I can take my 12 year old and lock him
in the house I can do that you can't do
that with him
no
and Cindy I I'm heartbroken for you I
can hear it on you love this man
I think that you love the idea of this
man
I think you love the story about this
man that you've told yourself for a long
long time
mm-hmm
and I think this man's redeemable I
think everybody is I really do
but he's gonna have to choose Redemption
you can't push him into it
no I realized that and that's so hard
yeah if I'm you if you're if you're my
wife if you're my well even my wife but
if you were my mom if you were my sister
I would tell you to call your two kids
and y'all go have an in-person meeting
if at all possible
and say I'm exploring
taking care of myself for the first time
in 30 years
I'm exploring being safe for the first
time in 30 years
I need some help with finances I need
some help with what comes next I need
some help talking to Dad
I'm gonna need to get a alcohol
counselor and see if we can get up here
and do one last intervention
and put some very strong boundaries in
place
and I'm gonna have to do the Nitty
Gritty of finding out what a one bedroom
apartment costs
and then man you're gonna have to grieve
it because you've been propping up this
picture of a perfect family for a long
time because you didn't want this to
happen and it did
have to own what happened and I've said
this before I'll say it again
the world is begging you Cindy and
everybody listening
not to keep replaying and propping up
these old pictures but to ask to ask
ourselves in that mirror
what are we going to do now
what are we gonna do now that's the
question all of us are asking
we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
today's song of the day
it's called Blues worse than I ever had
by the great Marcus King
song goes like this I got them blues and
it's worse than I've ever had when I get
out my job when I'm at home in my bed I
can't turn off my mind I can't seem to
unwind I've got them blues and it's
worse than I've ever had
oh just like a cannonball feel I'm
headed for a fall I got them blues and
it's worse than I ever had
that's why we're here
that's why we're here we'll see you soon
[Music]